what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the Super Bowl is tomorrow which
means as most people know we are getting
new footage for upcoming Marvel projects
and I've been getting a lot of questions
about what we can expect to see because
there are some conflicting reports out
there so we'll tell you what to most
likely expect tomorrow as far as Marvel
footage is concerned and first things
first if you do not know the Super Bowl
starts tomorrow Sunday the 12th at 6 30
PM eastern time and the Marvel spots
could literally play anytime during the
Super Bowl but of course right when they
are shown during the Super Bowl they
will be put online on YouTube so look
out for that and then look out for my
breakdown on the footage after but as
far as what to expect as far as footage
is concerned you can expect one or two
things one is that Marvel will have one
spot during the Super Bowl they will
most likely do a big game TV spot this
is what they typically do every year for
the Super Bowl and during this TV spot a
bunch of footage is shown for upcoming
Marvel projects now of course the
upcoming Marvel projects are Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania which is coming in
about a week Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 the Marvels and then of course we have
secret Invasion and Loki now Marvel
Studios over the past handful of years
has been known for putting a lot of
different footage for a lot of different
projects into one TV spot the good news
is that this spot is usually about two
minutes long so we can get a decent
amount of footage and what I'm expecting
in the big game TV spot is footage for
the Marvels which we haven't seen yet
footage for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania although probably not too
much since they're advertising so much
for that right now then secret Invasion
and Loki this is almost likely going to
be in one TV spot not an individual
trailer for any of these although there
have been reports in the past that have
stated that we could be getting a full
trailer for the Marvels however Insider
Daniel rpk who has a very great track
record of telling us when trailers are
going to be coming out said yesterday
February 10 that we can expect a full
trailer for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. now this actually makes the most
sense because like I said advertising
for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is
happening pretty much every day now yes
they'll promote it during the Super Bowl
but most likely during that big game TV
spot they've already released the teaser
and the full trailer as well as well as
many different scenes and since the
movie is only a week away it doesn't
seem likely that they're going to drop a
whole nother trailer most likely just TV
spots from here on out however we've
only gotten a teaser trailer for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and that's
only three months away actually less
than three months away and since we
don't have the full trailer for that
that is most likely what we are going to
get an individual TV spot for a full
trailer for Guardians 3. but also keep
in mind that the Marvels comes only two
months after Guardians 3 so that's only
five months away so giving us some
footage since we haven't gotten any for
the Marvels during the big game TV spot
also makes a lot of sense so this is
most likely what we're going to get
tomorrow two different Marvel spots
during the Super Bowl one being a full
trailer for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. the other the big game TV spot which
Marvel always does that will have
footage for the Marvel's Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania secret Invasion and
Loki season two so look out for those
tomorrow and like I said look out for my
breakdown on the footage that is
released after so don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out don't forget to
like the video and of course you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf